[Musica]
[Applauso]
prima di iniziare vorrei vorrei dire una
cosa importante perché vale sempre la
pena investire sulle persone qualche
anno fa investì come tutore su un
ragazzo una persona che con grande
entusiasmo continua a chiamarmi
chiedendomi di essere tutore della sua
tesi di laurea
oggi penso che beppe di brisco e la sua
squadra meritano un grande applauso
perché stanno facendo qualcosa di
veramente molto bello per la nostra
città bravo birth allora quando ci siamo
sentiti parlando di questa bellissima
iniziativa e mi sembrano molto singolare
l'idea di maunder kamber non tanto
perché si ha un'idea nuova
la verità è che si presta a molte
interpretazioni tra l'altro una di
queste è qualcosa a cui lavora da due
anni nel mio mestiere io mi occupo di
creatività sono un artista non solo un
agenzia ma ultimamente sento un gran
bisogno di fare qualcosa che non solo
sia utile non solo sia nuovo non solo
sia moderno ma che soprattutto serve
agli altri con una sommessa ambizione
che non serva solo a noi ma serva
proprio agli altri e quindi leggendo
proprio testualmente la treccani
ci sono delle parole chiave di bomber
cameri che ai tempi costituirono
materiale per la didattica è all'origine
del concetto del moderno museo poiché
all'interesse per il meraviglioso unisce
il bisogno di conoscenza sistematica
benissimo allora questo è un argomento
molto serio per me perché quello a cui
sto lavorando è un paradigma culturale
di fruizione culturale cioè quello che
sto cercando di realizzare non è tanto
l'idea nuova la novità le novità si
esauriscono in un attimo penso invece
che la sostenibilità culturale significa
anche fare qualcosa che non solo
sedimenti ma che venga poi tramandata e
ha sempre avuto una grande passione per
jacques de rita che ci ha lasciato un
pensiero illuminato mi diceva che
l'archivio è sempre stato una premessa
ad avvenire di per sé l'archivio
premessa ad avvenire con un problema che
ultimamente pensiamo che l'archivio sia
qualcosa da accantonare da tenere da
parte da archiviare con questa poi ansia
di fare qualcosa di nuovo invece l'ansia
per me in questo momento è fare in modo
che gli archivi arrivino agli altri che
vengono attualizzati e che continuino a
portare storie importanti per costruire
il futuro
oggi abbiamo sentito molte cose
interessanti vere
in alcuni casi anche angoscianti però mi
sono anche detto devo fare qualcosa nel
mio piccolo affinché le tecnologie non
sovrastino l'umanità su questa immagine
che chiede alla regia di mandare in onda
si svolge tutto il mio lavoro
vi ricordate quando a scuola ci davano
il fagiolo da mettere sotto il cotone
idrofilo a scuola io
credetemi non dimenticherò mai quella
esperienza vivevo a foggia in corso
giannone
per me quella piantina e stata una cosa
importante è stato qualcosa per cui miss
perdevo nei sogni pensavo che sarebbe
diventato un fiore un albero che mi
stimolava l'immaginazione produceva in
me un senso di incanto lo stesso che
produce in termini di incantesimo la
tecnologia quello è un tamagotchi io ho
assistito di persona un attacco
epilettico di una bambina che dopo non
essere riuscita a prendersi cura del suo
personaggino è andata in crisi
epilettica
guardate la postura di questo bimbo
sembra che danzi guardate invece
l'isteria se vogliamo di questa bambina
che li presa da un incantesimo che non
lascia scampo
ecco è su questa premessa che io oggi
come uomo
prima che come artista sto cercando di
dedicare la mia maturità perché ha 53
anni ho fatto delle cose importanti
ho fatto delle cose che mi hanno
permesso di comprendere che umanità non
vuol dire scimmiottare al cuore e
all'amore l'umanità è l'unica cosa che
possiamo contrapporre alle tecnologie e
l'unica cosa che ci può permettere di
non essere sovrastati dalle tecnologie
pervasive parliamo di realtà virtuale
parliamo di realtà aumentata che per
l'amor di dio attenzione uno non esclude
l'altro
spetta a noi saper stabilire una nuova
governance della tecnologia e l'uso che
ne facciamo
e io mi sono chiesto come posso
come posso portare questo sentimento
questa visione questo desiderio
questo bisogno prima che il sogno
e allora mi sono come dire concentrato
su un lavoro che oggi comincia a dare i
suoi frutti
partendo dalle cosiddette digital
humanities sapete c'è una
concettualizzazione molto interessante
che peraltro per me ex dj si sfonda una
porta aperta per chi mi conosce
sapete che sono un autodidatta e che
negli anni 80 90 ho passato la vita a
mettere un disco diverso ogni tre minuti
però nella mia esperienza di dj ho
imparato che la poetica del remix a una
grande e significanza nel senso che dove
non arriva la versione originaria un
remix può e mi dice oggi nella mia nuova
vita professionale che non sempre
bisogna reinventare la ruota e le visite
agli umani che cosa dicono emancipano un
attimino è anzi parecchio i contenuti
culturali le opere non c'è più bisogno
di far sì che un'opera racconti solo la
storia del proprio autore non c'è più
bisogno che sia imbrigliata in una
dimensione in una visione troppo
limitata la verità è che molto spesso
sono gli altri che hanno un'idea diversa
di quella che è la visione artistica di
un'opera qualche anno fa fu antesignano
con un progetto che racconto in 20
minuti il rinascimento impresa ardua
senza
dire la verità storica riuscì a
raccontare un'altra storia nella storia
parlando di bambini ecco dg taglio
mantis vuol dire questo riuscire a
rimani polare la cultura riprendere gli
archivi raccontare la loro storia e
metter ce n'è un'altra facendo in modo
che altri possano riflettere a loro
volta generare altri pensieri e altre
riflessioni
questo è un processo umanizzante e io lo
ottengo attraverso l'emozione sono
appassionato di emozioni vivo di
emozioni anzi prima mi ha fatto piangere
anche a me il mio amico non mi ricordo
musicista siamo amici di infanzia ma non
mi ricordo del suo 9 un è una
intelligenza artificiale non si fermerà
mai con le mani tremanti commosso
dicendo scusate non ce la faccio questa
e umanità per me di conseguenza oggi sto
lavorando a qualcosa per cui l'idea è
quella semplice di prendere gli archivi
ne abbiamo tanti oggi sto lavorando alla
divina commedia per le celebrazioni
dantesche del 2021
io sono emozionato commosso
anzi la vita mia mi prende anche un po
la strizza perché è impegnativo il
racconto di un uomo che ha cambiato
veramente la visione della vita ma io
non voglio parlare ai ragazzi della
divina commedia pensate alla divina
commedia e chicca oro legge piura divina
commedia che ha un testo portante della
nostra identità eppure mi chiedo come
posso portare agli altri la divina
commedia l'eneide l'umanesimo e il
rinascimento quando quando facemmo
questa cosa scrisse una storia narrata
da andrea bocelli quello che più mi
colpisce che mi ha portato al percorso
che ora vi mostrerò fu che la mia storia
raccontata per i bambini con una
chiusura che partendo dalle storie del
passato dicendo cose realmente accadute
poi avevano in sé una riflessione a un
certo punto un vescovo brasiliano ha
scritto alla città di firenze dicendo è
stata per me la più grande lezione di
catechismo della mia vita
ma se non ci avevo pensato e invece una
bambina mi disse signora il tuo cartone
era bellissimo però mi vergognavo a
guardarlo perché ci ha messo un sacco di
persone nude dentro riferendosi
dalla venere di botticelli e al david è
un'altra bambina ancora ma ha chiesto ma
perché è messo una signora nella
conchiglia e mi sono detto forse un
adulto con un occhio un po più birichino
avrà guardato le curve della venere ecco
io in questo momento penso che sia
arrivato il momento di mettere nelle
tecnologie contrapporre ai colossi del
porno del games e di tutto quello che
crea artificio e crea incantesimo
contenuti umani e umanizzanti senza
dover reinventare nulla semplicemente
portando agli altri con attualità e con
un linguaggio moderno le storie che
hanno ancora un grande significato da
questo punto di vista per cui con la
divina commedia che cosa farò utilizzerò
le grandi incisioni di gustave dorè per
un'esperienza museale aggiornata
attenzione niente che scimmiotti alle
mostre multimediali quella è un'altra
storia
una narrazione efficace potente moderna
e soprattutto atta a far sì che un
bambino di 10 anni non si annoia un
adulto di 70 non dica ma cosa che sempre
tutto questo allo stesso modo con aids
farm che è una realtà illuminata
stiamo sviluppando un programma di
didattica esperienziale quindi la stessa
storia la stessa esperienza porterà
entrerà nelle scuole attraverso una
didattica che non è quella frontale
professore alunno è nel mezzo i banchi
promosso o bocciato voti tutto diverso a
un bambino non gli si può spiegare una
storia esistenziale come la divina
commedia perché lui capisce con il
linguaggio della favola un adolescente
avrò bisogno del gioco ma soprattutto
noi abbiamo bisogno di entrare
attraversare le cose con un racconto e
non con una spiegazione ma non sono
ancora come dire contento di questo
binomio penso che sia arrivato il
momento attraverso la tecnologia di
restituire qualcosa agli altri
ed ecco che ci viene incontro la realtà
virtuale quindi non le persone che
vengono nella basilica di santa croce ma
nella basilica di santa croce che va
negli ospedali e carceri negli
orfanotrofi
nei posti dove c'è veramente bisogno di
qualcuno che si dedichi finalmente alla
bellezza umana non quella artificiale
io penso che questo sia fondamentale
bene sono molto ambizioso spiritualmente
e quindi penso che probabilmente
riuscirò a far sì che un nuovo progetto
una nuova idea di cultura possa
trasversalmente portare le storie del
passato al mondo ai ragazzi soprattutto
per far sì che quello che ci hanno
lasciato a nostra volta venga arricchito
di narrazione e restituito agli altri
perché abbiamo questo dovere storico non
possiamo pensare siamo tutti un po
[ __ ] scusatemi dalla tecnologia
io sono un grande fan della tecnologia
ma attenzione che il punto non è il dito
e la luna
di conseguenza penso che sia
indispensabile ognuno per quel poco di
far sì che queste tecnologie diventino
umanizzanti a questo proposito stasera
mi sembrava bello condividere con voi un
lavoro che ho fatto
su commissione di un collezionista una
famiglia di collezionisti che mi ha
commissionato una video arte con
un'unica richiesta
vorrei un tributo alle persone che ci
hanno lasciato un pensiero e ha cambiato
il destino dell'umanità e faccio la
tecnologia me lo ha permesso lo facciano
fa l'ho realizzata ma attenzione quanto
è bella questa storia dice ma non voglio
che sia solo per me voglio che sia
aperta vorrei donarle è già stata donata
alla comunità di san patrignano e il 15
domenica 15 nella basilica nel duomo di
matera per le celebrazioni della
chiusura della città capitale della
cultura europea
farò un attività che pensate quanto sia
tutto assolutamente multidisciplinare
questa opera si chiama pensieri
illuminati
stiamo raccogliendo pensieri ed i
bambini adulti uomini donne ricchi e
poveri la comunità
nelle chiese per il futuro e abbiamo
fatto in modo che questi pensieri
vengono elaborati da un processore e
diventeranno proiezioni sui musicisti ma
prima di questo ci sarà un piccolo
racconto digitale
breva la regia dedicato a chi ci ha
lasciato qualcosa
[Musica]
i pensieri incarnano l'umanità
inaspettati nascono nelle nostre menti
crescono nei nostri cuori e si
trasformano in parole mai dette prima
nonno forma né materia
affiorano spontanei e poi eva brano come
gocce d'acqua al sole certe volte si
sovrappongono come note musicali capaci
di comporre le armonie e le disarmonie
dell'esistenza incalcolabili incessanti
passano da coscienze ad altre coscienze
e si fondono in trame imponderabili che
talvolta hanno disonorato l'umanità
in un cammino
senza fine
tra destino e speranza
[Musica]
altri uomini e donne hanno continuato a
cercare la verità per poi trovare la
bellezza
[Musica]
cadendo e rialzandosi hanno saputo unire
cuore mente cielo e terra con pensieri
illuminati che non finiscono mai
pensieri illuminati di energia diventati
angeli che soffiano luce e tenebre sulla
vita lasciando a noi la scelta fra il
bene e il male
[Musica]
adesso questo
su questo lavoro voglio lasciarvi con un
pensiero non è la tecnologia 3d qui c'è
tanta tecnologia scanner permessi musei
vaticani a noi la scelta tra il bene e
il male e la tecnologia ci farà grandi
sorprese del futuro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
fermi tutti